[Music]
so bad news for our boy thick boy fake
boy boy thick boy fake boy fake boy
uh theo vaughn will be leaving the king
and the sting
what
then and then san jose salt lake city
just went on sale for october get you
some thickboy.com but uh appleton in
ontario you're up man
yeah then i got some sad news i'm going
to be taking a a step back from being on
king and the sting
and
[Music]
i just want to thank you guys for
um just being a part of my life and and
letting this show be a part of your life
and
now mind you i want to keep brendan does
not look happy
he
he's still doing his other podcasts he's
just not doing this one it's not like
he's taking a step back from podcasting
just so you know like you know and again
i want to say this we rip on on the
other comic scene a lot
we've always had a soft spot for theo
vaughn we like theovon i think he's
a dude who's really just feels like out
of place there you know yeah and like
the way he talks what he believes you
know i didn't realize remember when i
kept saying he probably wants to get the
[ __ ] out of la i didn't realize
that he
actually lived most of the time in
nashville
i didn't know that yeah so that's that's
also why he i think he's a little more
grounded than them because yeah he goes
to l.a and does all that [ __ ] but like
you know well yeah well so sorry i mean
you know when i say like la comic scene
i don't mean that they have to live
there yet but it's that there's there is
factions right and and he would be on
the lake you know what i mean like if
you were like separating the new york
comics and the la comics theo would
still be la comic you know
no wow but yeah but go back i want to
see the beginning again i want you to
see how mad he is yeah brandon's like
reading his stuff watch
and september in boston boston's the
29th of september through october 1st
that's laugh boston and then san jose
salt lake city just went on sale for
october get you some thickboy.com
but uh appleton in ontario you're up man
up where look at that
news uh let me see it again look at that
let me see if i can get it let me see i
see what i saw i saw it i saw it too
let me see if i can get it it's just i
caught that the first playthrough was
like there's something
there it is yeah look at that there it
is look at that
that body language
uh domo creole in the chats of papa's
fuming
i wonder what happened man
yeah and then i got some sad news i'm
gonna be taking a a step back from being
on uh king and the sting
and um
i just want to thank you guys for
um just being a part of my life and and
letting this show be a part of your life
dude dude the body language is rough
right
life and um
you know um
grateful to you burning man
oh
oh did you see the oh
guys i'm sorry but just look at brendan
when they about to do this don't look at
dio
just look at brendan watch watch watch
watch the body language like he was
shocked that he had to touch him watch
watch watch are you burning man
appreciate it
did you see that oh yeah looking uh
looking straight up
and looking straight up not looking at
him no
and yes today was a lot of fun and the
best
yeah it was the best it was that's why
you're biting the inside of your cheek
it was awesome funniest guy i know
that's not saying much
oh boy
thanks bro
what
happened
his emotions as he is at [ __ ] fajita
jokes this is this is
uh i'm sorry version he's not excellent
at hiding his emotions
no
here we go
and um
[ __ ] we've been doing what four years
i don't know has it been that long
is is he gonna cry papa
papa you gonna grab papa you squirt out
some tears papa is somebody else
abandoning you like you abandoned callan
after the new york times came out but
then realized it was cool when rogan
said was okay and then started doing the
show with him again
not to be specific
papa
you guys should go to a mexican
restaurant and share some
man yup
but why man hold on theo
you have all the control to make this
not end right so why is it ending
yeah i uh
man i really like those mic arms
you just gotta handle some [ __ ] brother
you know yeah there's a bigger yeah he's
gotta handle some [ __ ] a new co-host
yeah he's gonna handle his other podcast
so he's gonna still be doing
thing for you out there you know
yeah i don't know i i don't know what it
is exactly man i mean yeah i mean i uh
uh how about the king and the sing it's
him and lily singh ah
there you go what do you think guys
if you don't know this lily singh is a
bisexual person of color or she used to
be when she needed to be on nbc now she
could just lie and you know pretend
she's [ __ ] straight again
yeah i mean it's sad you know i feel why
are you doing it why are you doing it
why are you doing it you built an entire
set
but it's it's still an exciting show and
there's great people wait
you
brendan's gonna keep doing the show
with what's-his-face the the guy from
workaholics i think is the third guy
he's the king the wing
the king
sting
and the wing
and they should get joey diaz and call
it in bada bing what do you think i like
that let's do it
people here here and um
and
did you hear the chair creek
yeah you can just hear the individual
creaking of chairs this is a
kind of awkward
um
and
i think that that's
important you know that there's that
it's a great show still
uh
grateful of chris and eric and everyone
yeah and for people to enjoy man
and um
yeah i love you guys and uh yeah just
thank you so much there'll be some times
where i'll pop back in you know um
will you
but
just just i just don't want to kind of
leave that in the lurch i feel like i've
left it there for a while and it's
probably made it uncomfortable as a
listener maybe and this is a people
working here too you know so what what's
really going on man something's going on
i don't think we'll ever know not to be
able to you know be sure of me and um so
anyway thank you guys man i love y'all
and i love you bro love you brother you
know that
i love you bro you know that
quick pull back of the fist it'll look
away blink blink blink blink blink blink
the buzz for old times i should have
done this in the middle there hey ah
hold on
do you see the hair on the side
do you see the hair is that big gl b g l
b g oh yeah oh we got a big gay lion
spotting oh i love those is he the
producer for like all his shows is that
what's going on
well this show but for honestly
it kind of [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up our
career merch because every podcast has
an asian producer now that frozen's gone
we're [ __ ]
times do we maybe want to eat i'll eat a
hot chip
i told you it was a bad idea
okay
[Music]
fun
bro what happened